madame monsieur bonsoir voici le titre
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal à nantes près de 20000
manifestants dans les rues de la ville
pour protester contre la marée noire et
la responsabilité de total fina une très
forte mobilisation
un rapport des experts de bruxelles
épingle la france dans la sphère de la
vache folle la france qui ne prendrait
pas de précautions suffisantes les sans
utiliser des farines animales
les festivités du nouvel an chinois
cette année sera celle du dragon d'or
signe de faste et de changements partout
on célèbre ce nouvel an lunaire y
compris dans les prisons chinoises les
vacances à la neige les professionnels
du tourisme affiche un bel optimisme
l'arrivée les premiers skieurs le prix
d'un séjour
reportage dans ce journal mais je vous
propose d'ouvrir tout de suite cette
édition avec cette vraie belle victoire
du quinze de france qui débute en
fanfare le tournoi des six nations à
cardiff des tricolores en battu le pays
de galles 36 à 3 de quoi effacer le
souvenir des défaites précédentes face à
cette équipe christophe duchiron
christophe vignal en toute honnêteté le
début du match du gallois avec des
diables rouges n'ouvre le score sur
pénalité grâce à jenkins après un quart
d'heure de jeu
3 0 le stade du millennium tous les
habitants du pays de galles ont envie
d'y croire
après tout pourquoi pas côté français on
laisse passer l'orage et des espoirs de
l'adversaire et puis il entendu sûrement
le petit coq tricolore prend du muscle
la maison marc un drop suite à une belle
progression 3 partout et puis 9 à 3 à la
pause après deux nouvelles pénalités
autant les français ont fait preuve de
maîtrise autant le service d'ordre
commettre une petite faute aux dépenses
en laissant passer un supporter tout nu
les manifestement pas trop bronzé un peu
plus tard deuxième erreur un coq
s'infiltre sur la pelouse
il est quasiment insaisissable tout
comme le quinze de france en deuxième
période le ballon pour fabien galthié la
maison port castagnettes il s'enfonce
dans le camp gallois comme le couteau
dans la motte de beurre
c'est à dire très facilement surtout 30
le beurre et tendre magne arrive en
soutien et aplatit essai transformé 19 à
le deuxième essai tricolore est un
modèle du genre on voudrait rester
mesurer eu égard l'adversaire mais
reconnaissant c'est difficile il ya
d'abord thomas lombard qui a ouvert une
brèche dans la défense
il ya ensuite une monumentale percée de
man qui franchit le rideau gallois
dominici pour castagnetti aplatit ça
c'est du rugby comme dans les nues
malheureux gallois qui restait sur deux
victoires face aux français et qui
terminent la rencontre sur une bévue de
shane williams qui donne vêtements le
ballon et emile ntamack
score final 36 à 3
je travaillais pour rester humble même
si avec tours aujourd'hui est grande
surtout venus gagner ici au millenium
c'est quelque chose de fantastique mais
on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de chemin à
faire
militer discipline et défense l'équipe
de france s'impose mais dans quinze
jours les bleus accueillent l'angleterre
ça vaudra le coup d'oeil et rugby
toujours avec cette très belle entrée de
l'italie dans le tournoi des six nations
puisqu'elle a battu à rome les cosses 34
à 20 un mac sous serre et à la mi temps
où les deux équipes étaient presque à
égalité
france 2 qui diffusera ce soir à 1h50 la
rencontre angleterre irlande
la ville de nantes pour un jour capitale
de la colère et de l'indignation après
la marée noire qui n'en finit pas de
souiller le littoral atlantique
cet après midi sous le soleil et dans le
calme près de 20000 manifestants dans
les rues de la ville
une marée humaine qui fustige la
compagnie pétrolière total fina louis
carzou mahdi diawara cela se prononce
travail et autour de ce simple mot qui
résume parfaitement leurs sentiments ils
étaient plus de 20000 rassemblés dans
les rues de nantes pour une troisième
manifestation pour montrer que plus de
50 jours après la catastrophe de l'erika
les pastilles les boulettes sous les
nappes cette fois qu importe le mot le
pétrole répandu ne passe toujours pas
moi je ne peux plus supporter l'idée de
ce pétrole dans la mer rien à faire ça
m'exaspère
ça me met hors de moi alors bon je pense
que tout le monde vote noir manifester
si si si lens ne nécessitait pas
aujourd'hui alors qu'est ce qu'un bon
c'est sacré ça recommencera quoi du
second très concret des éleveurs ont bu
et au refrain qui appelait des réformes
plus structurelles les dizaines
d'associations de la fédération
anarchiste à la ligue de protection des
oiseaux s'étaient mobilisés autant de
nuances de sensibilité unis pour
condamner cette soudure uniforme et
rassurer les premiers concernés c'est
ouvert à tout le monde puisque le
pétrole fait pas de discrimination lui
passer les refrains de la colère les
manifestants entendent obtenir des
résultats concrets de total fina un
apport financier réellement conséquent
de l'état une profonde réforme des
structures et des règlements qui se
préoccupent de la mer et des excédents
qu'elle sut price a été fait par les
bénévoles des associations par les
collectivités locales depuis un mois et
demi n'est pas près de s'achever
ce qui explique que les gens soient
encore se sont vraiment concerné par eau
par ce qui se passe en réussissant à
mobiliser au-delà de toute attente dans
les rues de nantes cet après midi le
collectif anti marée noire et les
dizaines d'associations présentes réussi
à montrer une chose faite le plus d'un
mois et demi après la catastrophe les
conséquences de lui régler son compte
également très difficile à dépasser des
consciences et au même moment à la
défense devant le siège social de total
fina près 300 personnes ont exprimé leur
écoeurement
là aussi six semaines après le naufrage
de l'erika parmi les slogans inscrits
sur les banderoles on pouvait lire le
monde n'est pas une poubelle ou encore
empêcher les usages des pavillons de
complaisance
les ostréiculteurs du littoral
atlantique sont plutôt soulagé après la
décision de l'agencé de sécurité
sanitaire des aliments qui vient
d'instaurer des valeurs guides ou plus
exactement des seuils concernant
d'éventuels risques liés à la
contamination des coquillages après la
marée noire les experts de cet organisme
ont rassuré les consommateurs les
produits qui sont sur le marché ne
représente aucun risque pour la santé
bertrand cocq les critères de toxicité
définies par les experts de l'agencé
française de sécurité sanitaire des
aliments s'applique aux coquillages
comme au sel il concerne la quantité de
substances toxiques contenus dans le
pétrole que l'on appelle les apps
quantité considérée comme consommables
sans risque soit 0,5 ou 0,2 mg par kilo
selon le nombre de composés mesurer pour
être simple actuellement que le risque
sera plus important si vous mangez
beaucoup de produits d' avoir une
indigestion que de développer un cancer
cinquante ans et l'âge ans insiste
encore les coquillages actuellement sur
le marché ne sont pas dangereux ceux
touchés par la pollution de l'erika ont
déjà été retirés de la vente
du côté des ostréiculteurs la fixation
de ces critères destinés à ramener la
confiance est plutôt bien accueillie
reste un littoral atlantique plus que
jamais l'objet d'un contrôle sanitaire
très strict selon les professionnels les
analyses montrent une pollution
circonscrite à quelques zones bien
précises dont l'exploitation est
toujours suspendue dans le service des
grands prématurés du chu de nantes un
quatrième norris ans est mort ce matin
apparemment son décès serait sans
rapport avec la contamination par des
germes qui a provoqué la mort des trois
autres dans les airs alerte à la
méningite deux cas mortels pas deux cas
dont un mortel ont été détectés au
collège salvador allende à bourgoin
jallieu
un établissement qui compte près d'un
millier d'élèves une adolescente est
décédée une autre est dans le coma mais
ses jours ne semblent pas en danger
une cellule de crise est en place
laurent godon la méningite dont un cas
grave
donc on demande à tout le personnel de
prendre ses dispositions c'est à dire
voir votre médecin
la tristesse le dispute à l'inquiétude
au collège salvador-allende de bourgoin
jallieu après la mort hier d'une élève
de quatrième victime d'une méningite
cérébrospinale l'établissement
d'habitude fermée le samedi a accueilli
toute la journée les familles des élèves
et tout le personnel qu'il a fallu
prévenir d'urgence un traitement
préventif à base d'antibiotiques sera
administrée à l'ensemble du collège et
une cellule d'accueil médicalisé
répondra à toutes les questions des
familles
nous ne sommes pas compétents en matière
de médicaments
donc nous invitons les toutes les
personnes concernées à prendre contact
avec leur médecin traitant
l'autre collégienne âgée de 15 ans
admise hier dans le service réanimation
de l'hôpital debrousse à lyon serait
hors de danger
on a demandé que tous les enfants du
lycée soit mis aux antibiotiques mais le
risque pour les familles de ces mêmes
enfants n
six mille doses de vaccin anti biotiques
seront acheminés demain à bourgoin
jallieu avant d'être distribuée à
l'hôpital et aux médecins libéraux de la
région
lundi aucun cours ne sera dispensée au
collège salvador-allende
mais l'établissement restera hiver pour
informer les familles des 1000 élèves
concernés dans la sphère de la vache
folle la france ces derniers mois fait
prévaloir haut et fort le principe de
précaution or voilà qu'un rapport établi
par des inspecteurs de la commission
européenne accuse la france de ne pas
prendre des précautions suffisamment
draconiennes continuant à utiliser des
farines animales interdites dans
l'alimentation du bétail
françoise vallée chaque de vaud
régulièrement la commission européenne
effectuent des contrôles sur le terrain
pour voir si les états membres
respectent les normes à l'issue d'une de
ses visites en juin dernier
les vétérinaires de bruxelles on met à
jour deux problèmes essentiels
premièrement concernant le dépistage à
l'abattoir ce ne sont pas des
vétérinaires mais des techniciens qui
vérifie les animaux en clair le contrôle
l'abattoir n'ai pas fait dans les normes
d'autant plus que le rapport précise il
est inexistant le week-end et la nuit
pour les animaux abattus en urgence une
situation inquiétante sachant que cette
vérification est actuellement le seul
moyen de dépister les cas de vache folle
deuxième critique importante elle
concerne l'alimentation des bovins
l'analyse de leurs compositions révèle
la présence de protéines d'origine
animale en faible quantité certes mais
cela est strictement interdite on a
trouvé que le contre on dansait pts cas
spécifiques étaient pas suffisantes
alors c'est maintenant aux autorités
françaises de réagir et d
enfoncer leur contrôle et la france peut
encore vérifié à l'armée les éleveurs
elle peut également sensibiliser les
fabricants des marines elle peut
renforcer les contrôles des vétérinaires
français inspecteurs vétérinaires
français et je pense que le sauteur
français sont à la racine dans cet écart
là la commission souhaite donc renforcer
les moyens de contrôle de l'usb elle
devrait d'ailleurs annoncer
prochainement
l'utilisation obligatoire du fest de
dépistage pour tous les états membres
nos confrères du monde font leur mea
culpa l'information qui faisaient état
hier à la une du journal d'une cagnotte
de recettes fiscales supplémentaires à
disposition de bercy qui atteindrait le
chiffre record de 66 milliards de francs
cette information était erronée
le ministère des finances avait pour sa
part aussitôt démentie en corse alors
que demain il y aura deux ans jour pour
jour qui était assassiné le préfet
claude erignac
les élus locaux poursuivre leurs efforts
de rapprochement emboîtant ainsi le pas
à la rencontre organisée à matignon par
lionel jospin avec une question
désormais au centre du débat est il
souhaitable que la corse s'oriente vers
un statut d'autonomie
arnoux bouteille jenca l'assemblée
territoriale de corse
chaque vendredi les élus poursuites ici
le dialogue engagé au mois de décembre à
matignon
en quelques semaines la situation
politique vient de prendre un tour
nouveau
deux ans après la mort du préfet claude
erignac
c'est ce drame précisément qui créent
aujourd'hui peut-être la nécessité du
sursaut non pas la période la triste
période du préfet bonnet mais le sursaut
à suez par les insulaires eux mêmes le
grand changement porte un nom
l'autonomie du libéral josé rossi au
nationaliste jean-guy talamoni
les nouvelles alliances jugé hier contre
nature s'expose aujourd'hui au grand
jour les choses vont dans le bon sens il
est clair qu'aujourd'hui ce sont les
idées nationalistes qui sont reprises
par d'autres parcours d'autres forces
politiques et ça ne sont pas les
nationalistes renoncer à leur combat ils
sont peut-être les plus vigilants sans
aucun doute les plus critiques
les communistes de l'assemblée de corse
dénoncent les réformes audacieuses du
couple rossi talamoni tous les deux pour
des raisons qui peuvent apparaître
différents mais qui sont d'objectifs
pense qu'il est préférable de négocier
directement à bruxelles avec de temps en
temps dit des deux sauté paris parce que
paris ne comprendraient pas bien de
l'accord ce n'est pas juste un peu
partout sur l'île
l'idée fait son chemin et la question
revient pour ou contre l'autonomie la
droite et les radicaux de gauche sont
divisés mais le président du conseil
général de haute corse veut y croire
en europe il ya 86 région autonome alors
c'est pas même temps quelque chose de
très original c'est ce que tout pays
moderne occidentale est censé fait quand
il a une région qui est un petit peu
spécifiques comme c'est largement le cas
de la corse
donc ça n'a rien d'original à l'évidence
le sujet n'est plus tabou mais deux
nouveaux camps s'affrontent
la nouvelle ligne de partage dépasse
désormais les clivages traditionnels en
autriche nouvelle manifestation cet
après midi mais cette fois ci dans le
calme à vienne quelques 2000 personnes
ont défilé dans le centre-ville
protestants une nouvelle fois contre la
coalition de l'extrême droite et les
conservateurs qui est désormais pouvoir
hier soir près d'une cinquantaine de
blessés lors d'incidents entre forces de
l'ordre et manifestants qui ont été
évacués par usage des canons à eau est
fait aujourd'hui encore dans l'autre
ville d'autriche comme à salzbourg par
exemple quelques centaines de personnes
se sont rassemblés en signe de
protestation
cette journée de samedi marque le début
des vacances de février en août rich and
posséder et patrick 10 muhly se sont
rendus dans l'une des stations de
or divers les plus renommés c'est ici
près des pistes que les professionnels
du tourisme commentaient la nouvelle
coalition au pouvoir et ses possibles
conséquences après les sanctions
européennes
le ski c'est le sport national en
autriche et c'est aussi une richesse
le tourisme et notamment les sports
d'hiver constituent la deuxième source
de devises du pays
dans cette station du caddie berg en 46
75 pour cent des skieurs sont étrangers
anglais allemand italien
alors ici la question de l'impact de
jorg haider sur le tourisme européen en
autriche
ça agace parfois vous retourner en
france se voir le pen quand on voit tout
ce que vous avez raconté à la télé dans
son hôtel 4 étoiles
brigitte bogueys père coeur ne constate
pas de désaffection
il est un peu tôt mais elle ne cache pas
non plus une certaine contrariété
je sais que le tourisme est une activité
très sensible sûrement au début il ya
des clients qui ne viendront pas
finalement ils vont prendre onze son
terme que l'autriche vaut mieux que ça
les précédents sont plutôt rassurants
exemple en 86 lorsque l'élection de
courtes valdaï l'ancien officier de la
wehrmacht à la présidence autrichienne
avait fait de la mauvaise publicité au
pays
à ce moment là on avait prédit qu'il y
aurait des conséquences catastrophiques
pour l'économie du tourisme mais ça
s'est calmé très vite
et finalement il ne s'est rien passé de
ce point de vue les clients anglais
rencontré cet après midi à 4 baird
semblait rassurant qu'il soit d'extrême
gauche d'extrême droite
ces gens étaient lutte par les
autrichiens un point c'est tout en ce
qui me concerne je reviendrai l'année
prochaine
à titre d'indication à l'époque de la
sphère valdaï
l'autriche avait perdu 8 % seulement de
ces touristes américains au kosovo la
situation reste extrêmement tendue après
ces affrontements qui se sont produits à
mitrovica près d'un milliers d'albanais
massés près du pont central qui sépare
la ville du quartier servent se sont
heurtés aux troupes
la kfor six soldats français ont été
légèrement blessés lors de ces
affrontements qui ont duré plusieurs
heures ils font suite à d'autres
flambées de violences qui ont éclaté ces
derniers jours dans la partie serbe de
la ville provoquant la mort de huit
albanais illustration de cette haine qui
sépare les deux communautés serbe et
albanaise avec l'exemple de ce village
au sud de pristina où se sont réfugiés
des familles serbes sous la haute
protection des militaires français de la
kfor reportage richard binet jean
françois renaud c'est un vieil homme qui
se rend au marché sans doute par
habitude
on y trouve plus rien que ces quelques
pommes ou quelle personne ne prête
attention
depuis le départ des forces de belgrade
le village est totalement isolé du reste
du kosovo
les soldats de la kfor patrouillent en
permanence pour prévenir des
représailles albanaise mais pour les
serbes de fringe ceux qui les protègent
aujourd'hui sont les ennemis d'hier
après la défaite
l'humiliation nous sommes comme des
indiens parqués dans des réserves
les albanais peuvent travailler circuler
et nous on est là prisonniers dans notre
village kouchner et sa bande nous donne
des leçons de démocratie mais où est la
démocratie ici husson les résolutions de
l'onu
nous sommes des sous citoyens et nous
moisi sont ici au dispensaire
il faut aussi attendre pour consulter le
médecin de prix louge l'état de ce
nourrisson les se dit ready soins
intensifs mais ses parents hésitent à le
faire transférer à l'hôpital serbe
kumanovo pourtant distant d'une
trentaine de kilomètres
les gens sont terrorisés à l'idée de
traverser les eaux albanaises
la semaine dernière une jeune femme est
venue avec son enfant malade c'est que
je lui ai proposé d'aller à l'hôpital
sous la protection de la caf aurait
baissé elle a préféré perdre son enfant
plutôt que de sortir du village
au sortir de prix doux de la maison des
petrovic une des plus vieilles familles
serbes de la commune des soldats
français de la kfor
les visites chaque semaine pour évaluer
leurs besoins pour toute ressource
ils n'ont qu'une maigre pension de
belgrade mais ils aperçoivent en dinars
yougoslave qui ne vaut guère plus que le
papier sur lequel il est imprimé 100
francs par mois il ya le fils qui
voudraient bien partir mais qui n'osent
par la mer qui nous dit qu'il est son
seul soutien que sans lui elle ne
pourrait survivre
le père lui ne dit rien sauf pour
rappeler qu'en 1941 il s'est battu aux
côtés des français contre l'ennemi nazi
et qui ne comprend pas comment on en est
arrivé là
la mer pour raconter ses peurs les
pétards que font exploser des albanais
la nuit où tous du village pour les
effrayer un peu plus mais comprimé
qu'elle soit avalée pour ne pas devenir
folle
sur la route côtière de prix lounge
les blindés de la kfor poursuivre leur
surveillance
ce soir ils rejoindront leur
cantonnement à quelques kilomètres de là
cette nuit encore table et stana
attendra le jour pour s'endormir
le nouvel an chinois cette fête la plus
importante du calendrier célébré un peu
partout dans le monde par la communauté
chinoise hier soir c'était rencontre que
se déroulait à travers les rues de la
ville cette parade marquant l'entrée
dans l'année du dragon au rythme des
tambours et des cymbales l'an 2000 est
l'année où l'on fêtera le dragon d'or un
cycle de changements particulièrement
faste en chine nous avons choisi
d'évoquer ce nouvel an lunaire dans
l'une des prisons des environs de pékin
dans cet établissement la fête est
organisée
mais le coeur n'y est pas notamment dans
cette période où l'administration
pénitentiaire multiplient les exécutions
pour désengorger les prisons de
reportages de nos envoyés spéciaux
isabelle bessler tristan le braz c'est
le premier jour de chaque mois
d'habitude que les détenus prête serment
devant le drapeau rouge ce matin
19h52 degrés c'est le nouvel an lunaire
qui est marqué par cette cérémonie aux
caractéristiques quasi militaire
à
les mille hommes détenus ici ont tous
été condamnés à des peines supérieures à
10 ans corruption vol viol crime de sang
les juges chinois en la main bien plus
lourde que les nôtres les remises de
peine sont maigres et l'individu doit
s'amender
en se fondant dans le groupe dans la
joie
l'année du dragon qui commence au nom de
tous vos gardiens je vous souhaite une
très bonne fête dans les bâtiments de
détention
l'administration pénitentiaire a décoré
les parties communes
aujourd'hui les hommes incarcérés
peuvent préparer eux mêmes le plat
incontournable du nouvel an les raviolis
le nouvel an chinois c'est une fête
traditionnelle que tout le monde espère
bien sûr passer en famille moi comme les
autres
mais ici il ya aussi beaucoup de
gardiens qui sont privés de leur fête
familiale cause et on n'a pas bien
heureux des réponses convenues comme a
pris l avance
hier on m'a autorisé à donner un coup de
téléphone chez moi j'ai souhaité la
bonne année à ma famille mes parents
m'ont tous beaucoup encouragée ça m'a
vraiment fait du bien
les cellules prévues pour 16 ressemble à
s'y méprendre à des chambres et
militaires et le repas de fête s'y
déroule dans un silence de mort
les détenus ont bien appris leurs leçons
ici on apprécie encore plus les raviolis
qu'à la maison
ça fait vraiment du bien le gouvernement
ne nous a pas abandonnés
il donne des raviolis on nous traite pas
comme des bêtes attend monts et aux
provisions habituellement les détenus
font surtout des entraînements de basket
ball
pour inaugurer cette année du dragon
particulièrement faste c'est un vrai
match qui est proposé en guise de
spectacle à leurs camarades
pour les détenus particulièrement
méritant le parloir familial a été
introduit l'année dernière cette pièce
comme celles ci sont affectés aux
retrouvailles de couple ou de familles
des prisonniers modèle de
l'établissement et la deuxième fois que
je viens passer le nouvel an avec lui
trop ma femme peut venir passer deux
nuits avec moi ici avec l'ambiance de
cette chambre et sa présence sa me fais
l'effet d'être à la maison
c'est un détenu joue les compteurs
populaire et venté nouveaux mérites de
la prison parloir conjugale douche
téléphone menus diététiques
mais son énumération ne déchaîne pas
l'hilarité du public car seuls sont
autorisés les applaudissements convenu
un spectacle en détention est déjà un
énorme progrès pour cette chine
autoritaire qui veut améliorer son image
en matière de droits de l'homme la
spontanéité des détenus n'est pas encore
au programme l'arrivée en algérie d'une
importante délégation de chefs
d'entreprises regroupant les grands noms
de l'industrie de la finance française
parce que les autorités ont refusé leur
visa l'équipe de france 2 qui couvre
habituellement l'actualité en algérie
nous avons pris le parti de ne pas
relater ces événements en france sur la
route des vacances pas de difficultés
majeures pour cette journée pourtant
classée orange par bison futé seul un
bouchon de 6 km était signalé en début
d'après midi sur la rocade de grenoble à
la suite d'un accident
la journée de demain est classée verte
début donc des vacances d'hiver
aujourd'hui à vars dans les hautes-alpes
sous le soleil à la rencontre des
premiers vacanciers
nathanaël de rincquesen et l'ange ces
menaces se sont penchés sur le coup
d'une semaine de ski pour une famille de
quatre personnes
9 heures après avoir quitté paris la
famille avis touche enfin au but
un studio de 20 mètres carrés dans le
centre de vars la maman et ses quatre
enfants vont vivre ici pendant une
semaine c'est exigu mais l'appartement
leur est prêtée 3000 francs d'économies
une dépense au moins dans un budget ce
qui déjà important il faut savoir qu il
faut compter la location des skis du
matériel et puis les pentes et où donc
oui douze mille francs pour pour 5 c'est
ça me paraît tout à fait raisonnable à
vars la dépense moyenne d'une famille de
quatre personnes et de 14 mille francs
par semaine une somme importante
pourtant les dix-huit mille lits sont
presque tous réservés pour le mois de
février
compte tenu de son domaine skiable vars
se targue même d'être une station plutôt
bon marché bien il se trouve que grosso
modo on est encore à 30% minimum en
dessous des prestations qui sont vendus
notamment dans les spationautes
la plupart des stations de savoie avec
un forfait ville c'est à 590 euros pour
sept jours de ski les remontées
mécaniques de vars sont effectivement
moins cher que dans les grandes stations
savoyardes
mais pour les vacanciers l'économie
s'arrête au pied des pistes
faire ses courses aux sports d'hiver ça
coûte toujours aussi cher
la ruine la pop c'est très cher
effectivement cette pêche est plus cher
qu'à paris c'est pas il ya les lourds
deux skieuses n'ont pas eu besoin
d'augmenter leurs tarifs pour gagner
plus d'argent
le matin ils arrivent à faire du sort le
lendemain une fondue ce qu'ils font les
jeunes sur leurs ailes ont vu sortir la
veille à l'iphone d'un bac est une fois
ce sont les pistes les dépenses sont
vite oubliées les skieurs n'ont plus
qu'une idée en tête
glissez le plus longtemps possible près
de six semaines après les tempêtes qui
ont décimé une partie des forêts
françaises l'heure est à l'évaluation la
plus précise possible avec le travail de
l'institut géographique national à
l'aide de clichés ultra performant près
du ciel les dégâts de la tempête vue
d'avion
patrice pollet aujourd'hui la météo est
bonne alors les équipages de l'institut
géographique national se précipitent
vers les avions
depuis le début de l'année ils n'ont
jamais autant travaillé après avoir
photographié les vosges les bois de
vincennes et boulogne
les voilà maintenant au dessus de la
région parisienne des photos commandées
par l'institut d'aménagement de
l'ile-de-france
objectif de cette mission fixé sur la
pellicule les dégâts occasionnés par la
tempête au 1280 une commune qui encercle
la capitale sous l'appareil
deux caméras scrutent le sol une image
est prise toutes les dix secondes
l'intermédiaire d'un ordinateur des
détails jusqu'aux mètres près peuvent
être observés c'est ce qui intéresse
l'institut d'aménagement de
l'ile-de-france qui a dépensé 500 mille
francs pour 13 cents clichés mais ce
sont des photos précises obtenues à
partir de grands négatif on peut presque
compter un par un les arbres couchés ces
photos nous permettent en travaillant
avec deux photos et un stéréoscope de
voir en relief pour ça nous permet de
faire une estimation des destructions
probablement en trois classes aux quatre
classes grâce à ces photos
un bilan très précis de la tempête sur
l'île de france va être dressé en
septembre les particuliers bénéficieront
à leur tour de ce travail aérien il leur
suffira alors de passer commun dans
quelques mois c'est pourtant aérienne
reviendront à la photothèque nationale
que j'ai relie gêne à s'amender et tout
citoyen pourra venir les consulter pour
examiner en tellement ce qu'il en était
de leur propriété
l'institut géographique national est
loin d'avoir terminé son travail de
nouveaux contrats privés ou publics sont
en cours de négociation l'inventaire de
la france vue du ciel va durer jusqu'à
la fin de l'année
l'actualité sportive n'est pas que
favorable à la france puisque sans
gloire dès le premier tour de la coupe
davis des équipes tricolores se sont
fait éliminer l'équipe brésilienne de
gustavo kuerten et jamie hince a donné
le troisième point est la qualification
brésil christelle bertrand maryse
richard avant d'aller à la plage les
brésiliens sont venus voir gagner le
rythme que 35 degrés sur le court et
sous les casquettes
cédric pioline et nicolas escudé n'ont
pas le droit à l'erreur
ce match est à quitte ou double rahim et
11,6 et gustavo kuerten collée au filet
maîtrise tout de suite les français qui
perd de la première manche 6/4
la chaleur monte d'un cran et le public
hausse le ton
les deux français n'ont jamais joué
ensemble ils n'ont pas d'automatisme
les brésiliens en profite pioline et ce
qu'ils descendent alors mené deux sets à
rien
jamais les brésiliens n'ont fléchi le
double français est de plus en plus pris
de vitesse qui suivent ou sans bouger
des fois des
sadi
des petits problèmes d'entente des
petites combinaisons sont pas faites
exactement au moment
une position qui est passé avant cet
écart d'un point puis deux puis trois et
un et deux et trois sets aussi les
français ont été dépassés par la
situation réelle en jeu
pendant ce temps là les brésiliens sans
qu'il touche au but sans mal le brésil
s'impose devant son public
les français vont rentrer bredouille
cédric sur lille 900 se maintenant à son
avenir en coupe davis il ya plein de
jeunes
peut-être que je peux leur apporter un
petit fils tout ce que je peux je peux
les aider à s'améliorer à se développer
et ce sera eux qui feront les belles
rencontres par des grévistes des années
suivantes
les brésiliens remportent le match 3 0
c'est une double revanche pour la coupe
davis de l'année dernière et pour la
coupe du monde de football aussi
la disparition du réalisateur claude
autant lara qui a signé quelques
monuments du cinéma français dont les
engagements politiques notamment aux
côtés de jean marie le pen en font un
personnage controversé
olivier hinse claude autant lara a
traversé le siècle est traversé par un
beau jour de 1957 en compagnie de trois
gueule du cinéma français
paris l'occupation les petites rapines
non non non je vous ai dit qu'on est
pressé et ce soir c'est pas la porte à
côté un périodique au jeudi
vous avez dirait du temps le borgne en
toi maintenant car e cattoir c'est moi
qui la parole écoutée patron faudrait
s'entendre si c'est un mot marge nous
donnerait combien décorateur de cinéma
créateur de costumes claude autant-lara
mis au point à hollywood de procédés de
doublage de films en version originale
en 1923 il réalise son premier film et
signe en 1946 le diable au corps avec
gérard félicité je vais dicter après et
comment l'éviter d'habitude bon alors
écrit
mon chéri je tiens tout simplement parce
que le cinéma puisse s'exprimer en toute
liberté c'est la seule chose
intéressante
je ne pense pas qu'il doive y avoir
enfin dans les pays qui se disent
démocratiques des sujets tabous que l'on
ne puisse pas abordés on doit parler de
tout à condition qu'on le fasse avec la
retenue la modération et le tact
nécessaire
le tac le réalisateur on a parfois
manqué en 1989 il lance que les chambres
à gaz nazies sont un tissu de mensonges
et il agir
des mots qui n'oblige a démissionné de
l'académie des beaux-arts et du
parlement européen lui qui avait été élu
sur la liste de jean marie le pen
cinéaste reconnu mes hommes décrié
claude autant-lara achevé sa traversée
seul à 98,7 première grande exposition
qui signe la réouverture du centre
beaubourg avec pour thème le temps qui
passe qui s'écoule qui s'enfuit un thème
superbement traiter aussi bien à travers
la peinture que la vidéo le cinéma ou
l'archéologie
laurence piquet yange qu'elle est
d'abord dans le ciel que nos ancêtres
ont pris la mesure du temps qui passe
calculs savants ce à l'aide de ces
mystérieuses instruments le temps chacun
d'entre nous le perçoit différemment
extrême subjectivité face à la durée
l'exposition de vos goûts
traite du temps sous plusieurs aspects
la mort comme finalité une réflexion
présente dans de nombreux autoportraits
comme celui-ci d'andy warhol le temps du
cinéma et des passions humaines qu'il
immortalise le temps de l'amour incarné
par simone signoret et juste à côté par
ces deux horloges régler à la même heure
oeuvre intitulée les amoureux parfait
le calendrier de la civilisation maya à
nos jours ils rythment l'année
le temps du travail
impossible d'y échapper un sujets
explorés par la vidéo la photo et par
des objets tels que cette horloge
pointeuse
après le travail
la délivrance le temps libre est traité
avec humour dans ce film dans ce bar les
clients viennent tuer le temps le temps
de loisirs
ces oeuvres pessimiste dans laquelle
chaque visage prend la forme d'une
horloge
c'est pas une image du temps livre
extrêmement positif c'est sûr
c'est une très belle oeuvre d'art et
c'est une oeuvre d'art qu une dimension
tragique
c'est une oeuvre d'art qui peut-être
dans l'évidence la vacuité du temps
irréversible le parcours du temps à
bourbourg ta chaise derrière ce rideau
sur une photo prise par le télescope
hubble
voici une étoile qui explose profitez de
ces derniers couchés de soleil la
lumière disparaîtra son tour dans 5
milliards d'années
alors autant prendre le temps de vivre
plus léger c'est la fin de ce journal je
vous en rappelle le principal titre à
nantes près de 20000 manifestants dans
les rues de la ville pour protester
contre la marée noire et la
responsabilité de total fina une très
forte mobilisation dans un instant la
météo nathalie rihouet 20h55 100% a
prévu un divertissement présenté par
marine vignes et arnaud poivre d'arvor
demain à midi dma paul amar aura pour
invité françois hollande
quant à moi j'aurais plaisir de vous
retrouver demain dès 13 heures je vous
remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2